^- Whooo, Chris Pratt and
^- Zoe Saldana.
^- And we're going to read some of these tweets,
^and it's gonna be amazing.
^- Shout out to the woman I heard coming out
^of the theater saying "Mmmm M'baku thick."
^- (laughs)
^- Okay.
^- I'm here to announce my new favorite Disney princess
^is Shuri, she must be protected.
^I would die for her.
To be called a Disney princess,
it hasn't sunk in yet how amazing that is.
It's actually overwhelming, I might cry
I have some fug tears.
^Let's not do that.
^- Mantis: the galaxy looks beautiful.
^Drax: You know who else is beautiful.
^Mantis: Me?
^Drax: No.
^Ily, ely?
^I love you.
^Ilysm: I love you so much.
^Ildiwidwh: If Loki dies in Infinity War,
^I'm dying with him.
Bless.
^- Y'all think when Vision is dying in Infinity War
^they'll put him in a bag of rice and hope for the best?
^- It says in Guardians of the Galaxy Volume One,
^Peter Quill has mommy issues.
^In volume two, he has daddy issues.
^In Infinity War, he has in-law issues.
^(laughs) Ain't that the truth son.
^- Cancel Infinity War and just give me two hours
^of Pepper, Okoye, oh, Shuri, Nakia, Nat, Gamora
^and Valkyrie just sitting in a room talking about
^how stupid the men in their lives are.
^- Wanda Maximoff is the strongest Avenger
^and she will be the one to save the universe
^and defeat Thanos.
^Once she does that all you haters are gonna
^give her the recognition she deserve.
^- (laughs)
Okay, well first off I didn't know I had haters.
^(laughter)
^- I wanna know if Bucky got to eat a plum
^before he went back on ice.
^I really hope he did.
That's all he wanted was some plums back in Civil War,
^the rest was history.
^- So I'll be honest, if Robert Downey Jr.'s Tony Stark
^doesn't at some point say "No shit, Sherlock"
^to Benny Cumbers' Dr. Strange,
^I'm going to consider Infinity War
^an utter and complete failure.
It's an utter and complete failure.
- I tried so hard to get that line in there.
^- It's so corny.
^- Drax be thinking like, "This is Iron Man?
^He's not even made of iron."
- [Don] (laughs)
- That is what Drax be thinking like.
^- [Don] Yeah.
^- Starlord: Hey, you're the strongest avenger like by far.
^- Thor: Okay, Gamora is absolutely the strongest guardian
^but thank you, I love you too.
I am, I am the strongest.
^- True, it's true.
^- Everybody is excited to see who dies in #infinity war.
^I'm just excited to see the banter
^between Rocket and Falcon.
I don't talk to raccoons, I eat 'em.
^- Do you ever think that if Loki and Thor
^survived Infinity War, they would be close brothers again,
^and would start a whole new Asgard
^that peacefully ruled by both of them,
^and although it's too good to be true
^I still think it's beautiful in my dream.
That's so sweet.
Well that is lovely, thank you for that.
^Maybe it's a beautiful dream, let's leave it there shall we.
^- Peter Parker showing up to Infinity War.
^Teen Olympics overslept (laughs), lost coat,
^said (bleep) on TV, and won the U.S. first gold.
That's definitely me.
- (laughs)
^- I hope Infinity war devotes several scenes to Shuri
^clowning Tony's tech.
I do too.
^- If Tony doesn't call Rhodey a stupid pet name
^and hugs him in Infinity War, then what's the point.
You know, love Julie, I gotta agree.
This is 10 years and coming,
I still don't have a stupid pet name from Tony,
and barely a hug.
^We hugged once.
^- Wanda says, "We should try spicing things up
^in the bedroom."
^- Vision says: "Oh, good idea."
^- Later.
^Wanda: "What is this on the bed?"
^- (whispers) It's paprika.
^- Mantis is so underrated but if my soft girlfriend
^even has one scratch on her throughout Infinity War,
^I'm gonna fight Thanos and all his allies,
^Steve Roger's style.
It's from a girl I think.
- Yeah, she's asking--
- Oh, that's cool, yeah I'm a girlfriend.
Thank you.
^- Why is no one talking about Sam Wilson
^with a beard in the new Infinity War poster.
Boom!
I don't know, I think my beard looks actually
pretty good.
To say I can't grow facial hair.
- I thought it was very Shaft.
- That's what I said.
- I thought maybe that's what you're going for.
^- Alice: This is the most brilliant British picture
^I've ever seen.
Alice there's going to be a role waiting soon.
^- April is Gamora, Derek is Peter Quill
- And Ben as Thor.
- Okay so this is from Parks and Rec.
So she's saying that this is you.
- Uh huh.
- And that is me and Hemsworth.
- Oh.
- Isn't that funny?
You'd be like this is my boyfriend, Quill,
and this is his boyfriend, Thor (laughs).
- But I have a question, are you both my boyfriends?
- Yeah.
^- She's a baddass.
^- M'Baku could blow my M'Back out if he wanted to.
(cheering)
- I've gotten the dirtiest tweets.
- That's an awesome one.
- You got.
- [Winston] I've gotten Disney after dark.
That's what I got, that's what I got.
- [Anthony] You got that Skinimax.
- [Winston] (laughs)